[Music]
the VW Golf a living legend in 2012
every fifth golf sold in Germany was a
wagon version now there's a variant as
it's called in Germany for the seventh
generation golf - it's been completely
redesigned it's up to 105 kilograms
lighter than its predecessor and offers
100 litres more storage space the
exterior is new with tighter body
proportions new gasoline and diesel
engines make the model up to 15% more
fuel efficient and the upgraded XDS +
differential lock has improved the car's
performance around curves unlike with
previous cases explains designer Stefan
Walberg this year VW has brought out a
golf wagon together with a golf
hatchback the variant and plus are being
launched at the same time rather than
successively the aim was to underscore
the concept of the golf family death
cliff Cougars Titan
the front is no surprise recognizably a
gulf the station wagon and the hatchback
are the same up to the b-pillar but the
wagon is a whole 30 centimeters longer
than the four-door hatchback
[Music]
from the rear door back the new variant
has a number of design changes but it's
still clearly a golf Minette contigo FG
the striking form of the c-pillar
clearly displays golf genes notes the
designer this pillar has characterized
the golf through all seven generations
these characteristics are found in the
station wagons de pillar to beyond that
the go variant has familiar golf design
elements like the divided rear lights
that's heck let's go if I can mama
standard with all seven types of engine
are a start/stop system and brake energy
recuperation to cut fuel consumption by
transforming motion into electrical
energy we tested the most powerful
gasoline engine which delivers 103
kilowatts or 140 horsepower it's Prince
to 100 kilometers an hour in 8.9 seconds
the manufacturer claims it burns only
5.3 liters of premium gasoline for 100
kilometers
[Music]
often Oya test-driver clothes needs fits
finds the handling is that of a true
golf the suspension is a compromise
between sporty and comfortable but then
again the car is meant for transporting
cargo our tester recommends the 122
horsepower gasoline engine or the 150
horsepower diesel the extra power pays
off on a long trip on the highway fully
loaded
if the rear seats are up the trunk holds
100 litres more cargo than its
predecessor and if you fold them away
and load the car to the roof the storage
space grows by 125 litres to 1620 the
trunk elegantly excused awkward
protrusions and corners and the low
trunk silk makes it easy to load up
[Music]
but what are the differences between the
gulf wagon and it's big brother the
pissant variant which will pacify the
designer explains that the two wagons
target different age groups and income
levels
Cassatt customers want more space than
the Gulf offers the trunks are equally
large but the Passats interior is
roomier the Passat is 20 centimeters
longer this Gulf is 4 meters 56 long the
Passat almost 4 meters 80 the Passats
engine has a bit more punch to he'd
recommend the goal for young families
with two kids the Passat is more
conservative and Passat talked at was
conservative era he account
[Music]
we're impressed with the interior but
then we're looking at the top version
the Highline with all kinds of extras
our model has a manual transmission with
six years but a 7-speed DSG automatic
transmission is also available among the
optional extras is a large touch display
in the middle console it relays vehicle
data and has a navigation function the
air conditioning in this version has a
two zone temperature regulator
yeah the go variant was always a car for
families and sales that's changing now
since our car tester the design is
attractive inside and out making the car
distinctly more earnest and modern and
the story space has increased markedly
to 605 liters 2 litres more than even
the current posad you can see a lot of
people preferring it also because in
Germany the starting price where the
golf variant is almost seven and a half
thousand euros lower than for the Passat
variant you can get your hands on a new
golf wagon for just under nineteen
thousand euros a tempting prospect and
not just for young families
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]